talk about your relationship with peep
man because i know you guys toured a lot
together i mean obviously you got the
tattoo i know that it hurt you a lot
when he passed yeah so that was
why i didn't meet him a long time ago
right so my homie mikey was my producer
my best friend
he played his record in the studio and
he was like yo check this guy out and i
was like ah show me more you got me like
but let me get into it so he showed me
more like oh this kid's tight
and then i think i'd hit him up on
instagram
and then we just clicked like thank you
to ellen i met him and then we came
friends we went on tour together it was
me
peep smoke perp and then yeah we just
kept connecting ever since wow the whole
time we met
chill a few months went on tour yeah you
guys uh
you know i think peep is like one of the
i can't even
imagine where he'd be at now
life is one of the most and not even
saying that cats that's like my brother
i in this generation he is one of the
most influential people because i think
of like where a lot of music has gone
uh and
that was like the kind of [ __ ] he was
just already doing right yeah 100 even
from big records now from big art like
it's definitely from peep or an
influence he'd have been a you know
you know i think like mgk right that's
my guy but you know mgk is making rock
music now like i'm like man
people would have had that whole lane
just on lock like you know what i'm
saying like even like shout out to juice
world you know juice world did a lot of
that kind of [ __ ] and i think juice will
obviously rest in peace a legend but i
definitely think people was like ahead
of his time i did i would i was a juice
because he was living out here and we
were in the studio he was like dude i
love peep yeah i listen to people all
the time yeah no peep i think it it's
it's you know
it's one of those guys who
before he was even commercially known
like he had like a cool following and
it's like who would have known what
would have happened you know what i mean
yeah i think if he was still alive 100
one of the biggest artists well i i do
think he's a huge artist but he would
have definitely been like running he
would have transcended yeah yeah into a
whole different world that he didn't
even realize